et c'est en ce mardi 5 mars que cette
incroyable aventure commence à lara
croft à vivre et elle a réussi à
survivre face aux dangers présents sur
l'île lieu de monde c'est ce quiz et
l'on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour le
premier épisode sur tomb raider le
nouveau là qui sort de 2013 non non pas
sur celui de 1980 18 avant jésus-christ
alors c'est parti une nouvelle partie
tout de suite
donc vous voyez j'ai vraiment jamais
joué normal on est des guerriers mais
pas trop quand même
donc j'ai augmenté le sombre dans les
cinématiques en suisse à des choses
extraordinaires
acte pas de qui nous sommes j'avais
enfin décidé de partir faire mes preuves
pour chercher la voiture
mais à la place
c'est l' aventure qui m'a trouvé super
bourrin
or des boutons non jarret jack jack dans
les instants les plus sombres quand
votre vie vous abandonne
il y a toujours quelque chose quelque
chose qui vous maintient en vie
quelque chose qui nous pousse à avancer
oh
ouah c'est tellement bien fait la vache
ok waouh on est direct au gameplay
alors pour s'en sortir sur cette île de
moi de mon côté j'ai juste pris une
petite bouteille avec de la grenadine et
de l'eau alors ça va être le rituel
route et son épisode on se cale tous
avec de la grenadine et blu devant le
jeu allez c'est parti vous le rêve
prendre le peuple t'a permis
elle m'a fait la gauche
ça va c'est pas trop bloc beaucoup
d'allées bancaire et où l'armée l'a
depuis hier
mmh
le jeu
on verra
on n'est pas troublé c'est déjà ça
vendent en bon état
ok
au hall et chiappe bon [ __ ] ça
commence direct on est direct dans le
journée pris dedans la voie où ça a
l'air surprenant pour le moins ça me
fait penser un petit peu à part cry un
bon c'est pas parce que trois loyal du
far cry non vraiment c'est un peu le
même délire toi bien ils ont un affront
et elle elle tombe en bateau sur le nil
affreuse et sectionnées par les
piannencs corde
on va devoir s'échapper du village de
sang ça va être sympa son poteau à la
vache c'est quoi ça c java de star wars
mais que fait-il ici crystal dynamics
oh oui alors oh [ __ ]
arrivé
[ __ ] dans ce mode du glauque et 6 mhz
alors fait balancer comme une grosse
larme
voilà voilà
on est tombé sur une île de quoi là
qu'est ce qu'il faut sur cette île mais
je viens de liberec haut
oh [ __ ] de merde ok donc voir qu'on a
ouvert le feu alors on essaie de
comprendre
ouais très très mal je te le fais pas
dur
waouh c'est dégueulasse
oh [ __ ] bon alors là logiquement elle
devrai être recueillis par des gens quoi
oh là là là on est tout de suite dedans
la vache c'est vraiment impressionnant
je suis encore choqué la sas et comme
far cry jacked et d'en bas comme on dit
oui aux mondiaux on a trouvé jésus est
pas tous ses pieds puis temps mais c'est
glauque
c'est quoi c'est un ogre qui vu la météo
j'ai vu huy où vous pourrez paquet
d'arrivée salaire mais enfin horde
allons affronter un feuillet ça prend
feu extrêmement vite ça comme la patafix
et prédécoupés ça c'était prévu les
besoins droit beaucoup de magdebourg
j'annonce
ah ouais [ __ ] j'aurais jamais dû
qu'elle passerait moi tu as beau être
fine quand même c'est pas vrai alors lb
ok d'accord a pour sauter vos actions
des banques à dévoiler ici
wallis où ils sont allés comme just
cause en fait simplement alors il faut
du feu ouais alors attendez on va
prendre le feu on va pas l'âme de feu on
va te louper le feu non mais tarde faire
super mario ou c'est bon j'aimerais
inflammé alors déjà les interactions
avec le décor je kiffe
c'est vraiment pas mal bon laissons
l'air un peu craqué abbas maintient up
réduit les tac c'est parti on peut être
en bois ça va péter
bouscasse oussama des français les
oreilles n'ont elles pas là dedans
voilà là mais la queen j'ai pas le gall
c'est assez le célèbre je veux juste
aider mon cul ouais la teinte orange
dans les fêtes gérard qui sait quelques
tubes en temps [ __ ] c'est glauque 1
waouh
allez lara chemin au shit
oh là là là là c'est impressionnant a
way to cpc rencontre pourra jamais du
mouvement sont plutôt réduites aux
chiens
[ __ ] moi perso je ferais jamais ça
jamais de tout mettre
c'est juste pas possible quoi
déjà un bâton de ma jambe égal à trouver
une sortie face à skyrim et tout comme
ça au sérieux alors par le feu n'ont en
fait non
lv faut que je sorte d'ici là les
objectifs d'accord il faut être l'autre
côté mais comment comment on va pouvoir
faire ses mines
résumons
alors on va explorer un petit peu tout
ça hein ma foi fort bien coucou à mais
il faudrait du feu à laoag aux chiffres
10,2 j'ai deux nouvelles oeuvres partie
hop on prend le feu immédiat ch'tis
qu'on peut souhaiter faire un peu
n'importe quoi ça c'est cool on va
enflammer ça ça va faire que ça va
tomber à l'échec
sur ça a tourné et ça a cassé le plus
attention
devant non je ne suis donc pas gamins là
où aller ouais on prend son élan et eau
je sais pas comment j'ai trouvé ça mais
j'ai trouvé ça
ouais
d'accord mais encore alors est-ce qu'il
faut peut-être là bas voir
on va aller on va les voir on va le voir
ce que ça met dedans tu as par contre
s'est fait transpercer là encore en vie
tranquille papa je couvre ok mais je
veux bien mais à ok pour [ __ ] le feu y
y
yes
oui au fait vous avez des tripes on voit
la boulette elle va glisser et ont fait
l'attraction yade explique génial alors
oui alors rien il va y avoir un arbre de
talent ça nous permet d'avoir un arbre
de talent il semble avec des compétences
pour avoir dans les faits ça va être
assez un aspect siens pouvaient rpg
waouh cheat codes gênant et astérix de
rigueur merde je crois qu'il fallait pas
sauter ici
excusez moi j'avais bien n'importe quoi
autant pour moi allergique au rejet leur
linge il sait pas combien il faudrait
qu'on a dû nous prévoyez car en
bouteille par épisode
oh moi ok ça au parti
là ça va s'effondrer encore que je passe
au dessus et pas dans tout
la wau
heureusement que ce soit un peu de shit
et
oh [ __ ] mais c'est qui au mieux aux on
a tué la loi
dans la dune ta maison bleue
le y fallait y aller il fallait y aller
un ok ça comme c'était vraiment un
championnat
tiens
au xinjiang
je me demande se trouve c'était
peut-être vraiment un gentil en fait
c'est ça qu'ils veulent
c'est
alors halte au sort des photos
marsupilami quoi c'est normal
alors là on m'appelle le prônent la
gâchette tebbal ton bébé gauche couche
oh [ __ ] t'as c'est super le faut être
réactif comme eux
à droite droite y est allé la lumière
avec un gros plan sur son cul ou des
rockets allez vas-y vas-y vas-y toi on
l'a fait
ok on est remonté à la surface [ __ ]
enfin attendu franchement j'aurais pas
dit honnêtement
alors vas pas des pianos en salle et un
ouais un avion qui s'est crashé
notamment
on
c'est bon
je m'adresse effet sainte marie jeanne
est super l'oncle tom raider à génial
super jolie super joli j'adore waouh
vous la jouer comme ça sur l'île
waouh je veux quête du chien des chiens
du loup alors l'objectif faut qu'on se
souvienne de ses touches très
importantes ont passé importante que ça
là pour le coup je dirais plus par la
caunette mans
en fait non non ne pas sauter un peu
cédé il ya du hockey a commencé à parler
le canot de sauvetage
mais où sont ils
ils ont dû avancer dans les terres bas
mais ils sont tombés sur les autres
choses les autres mecs bizarre là autant
de victoires oh là là on va apprendre à
gérer l'équilibré alors leur fait je
pense c'est un petit peu le début donc
le tuto on va dire pour apprendre à
jouer justement comment s'est tranché
marc par contre tu peux accès au ta mère
au nom ça par contre ça venait pas de
moi mais voilà donc c'est comme ça voilà
mais pourquoi se met debout c'est moi
j'aurais dit mes bras et tout autour du
tronc alors voilà parfait
allez go on va y aller
ouah c'est super joule ouest 2 on l'a
j'adore les sauts ils sont immenses et
paie tout réalisme et le gameplay va
être tout un intéressant car ça ça alors
voile et sous la grotte à mon avis on va
continuer par ici
ok je suis comme le régime fiscal
ok vous jeter dessus
ok je dirais que j'ai vu ici gp2x
elles sont aussi ce côté
et pourquoi tu passes par là mais
c'était pas de quoi je dois de trucs le
moins stable du monde sur terre alors il
ya un petit côté assassin's creed on
peut voir
waouh shit enfin je dis ça parce
qu'elles n'ont pu tous mais je veux dire
les filles d'ailleurs bientôt une vidéo
sur toutes les infos que vous devez
avoir su inscrire deux cas je compte sur
vous pour la mater pour me dire votre
avis sur le jeu faisait loi
je pense que ça vous intéressera tu as
enfin depuis le temps que j'attends ce
[ __ ] tu aimerais d'autant qu'on voit
des images et tout est là on y est à
pied sur un d'accord ok pour sauter sur
une parodie
alors je sens qu'on va un petit peu
galéré bon heureusement cette fameuse
touche nous montrera aux foires et
salons
ok alors
basculera du matériel de secours genre
marqueurs sam
ils ont dû passer par là
une caméra ça va être pour zoomer de
loin ça des allumettes pour allumé les
torches les autres trucs
est ce que quelqu'un portant
ah mais celle sur la fréquence des
ennemis ça pas le club où j'ai plus qu'à
vendre ou merde fallait faire x 1 je
suis mort ou si j'aurais fait x ça
aurait ça aurait fait un autre chemin
je me demande non je pense que là on
peut même faire et ne pas faire et que
ça
simply la spa paradis axa la pluie d'où
l'appui pas trop mal fait d'ailleurs le
jeu est vraiment bien fait écouter jeu
on a un début de coups de coeur un par
un par un coût de 40 hier un début et
via mail mec trop chaud look avec des
boucles hommage à tous ceux qui ont
regardé sa poitrine monde le pervers
traces de quelqu'un ça au nom l'aude la
plupart font que j'approuve pas on va le
voir chasser l'ours pour se faire un peu
de respect est ce que quelqu'un entend
aller répondait
j'ai peur pour toi t'as quel âge ne sent
pas trop la camara et trompe bizarrement
pendant les cinématiques hors jeu pas si
vous voyez ça c'est bizarre
aulas lui m'aide c'est un coton-tige
paul bordel over megan et of the death
[ __ ] tu interagir et le bois mouillé à
ces salles us etc près 1000 et voilà
c'était prévu id tout est prévu et sur
cette île ces styles a pris mouillage
bateaux n'ont eu droit aux
alors
c'est une équipe assez bon bref
diabétiques et le jour des faits la
bursa
autre autre islam
alors est ce que l on regarde les vidéos
est ce qu'elle va filmer genre jour 1
je viens d'arriver sur les îles voici la
future référence mondiale de
l'archéologie
lara croft dans son habitat naturel elle
était la recherche du royaume perdu du
via ma taille sur les traces de himiko
la mythique reine solaire une de mes
ancêtres semble-t-il sommes sérieux là
mais je sais ma belle j'essaie juste de
détendre un peu l'atmosphère
tout le monde est tellement à craon dix
mois ce qui préoccupe je tiens quelque
chose j'en suis persuadé mais je sais
pas si le cdh au bout de votre compte ou
si il faut qu'ils m'écoutent lara
personne ne connaît ce sujet aussi bien
que toi
sérieusement je dis pas ça juste pour te
rassurer ce genre de fille confiance et
ross aussi que trop bon ça va aller
allez c'est le moment de faire une pause
faut se détendre à son sur le d'accord
d'accord et sa motors merci elle n'est
pas toujours aussi sérieuse honduras
images et secondaire mais comment
pouvez-vous à chiens et que je ne prends
pas cette expédition au sérieux la ras
il n'y a pas que la famille de sam
moi aussi je finance ce projet nous
jouons tous gros dans cette histoire et
on savait que ce ne serait pas une
promenade c'est précisément pour ça
qu'on doit aller vers l'est vers l'ouest
rien ne laisse croire que rien ne laisse
croire que les biens bataille soit
autant à l'aise tous les ouvrages de
référence disent le contraire
cela dit leurs auteurs n'ont jamais
trouvé le ya ma taille
j'en ai déjà parlé avec ross ça ne rime
vraiment à rien de marcher sur les
traces des autres docteurs whitman
ne comptez pas sur moi pour jouer ma
réputation sur une de vos lubies c'est
moi seul qui dirige cette expédition
puis quand vous n'êtes pas les seuls
terrains sans caméra derrière vous chez
30 ans d'expérience de doctorat dont un
en histoire de l'extrême orient d'alors
occupez vous plutôt de votre bateau
navire docteur whitman
c'est un navire pas besoin de rapports
d'écoutés faire cap vers laisse nous
mènera directement dans le triangle du
dragon c'est là où nous devons aller là
rama petit recueil tu sais bien que je
serai prête une importe où mais j'aime
pas cet endroit ces tempêtes ferait
passer le triangle des bermudes pour
disneyland pour certains récits raconte
que la reine himiko pouvait invoquer des
tempêtes les mythes sont souvent des
déformations de la réalité et si le lien
bataille se trouvaient à l'intérieur du
triangle
voilà une image satellite montrant
l'intérieur du triangle du dragon une
dizaine pas envie tant qu'il ya de l'eau
ne me dites pas que c'est assez sérieux
reyes a raison on n'a pas les moyen de
tergiverser c'est maintenant ou jamais
la rall mérite d'avoir des idées et une
carte c'est moi le capitaine c'est moi
qui décide on va aller dans le triangle
du dragon comme bon vous semble d'accord
donc au final on va aller là où leurs
aveux bas ce qui expliquerait justement
pourquoi on s'est pris la fameuse
tempête qui disent que là-bas par la
tempête
ça me semblerait d'ouvrir ici bon à tous
les coups à la fin on aura la petite
équipe aux essarts de s'en sortir du
tout niké sur l'île et trouver ce flou
alors on va apprendre à chasser etc je
pense tu peux pas rester là rien voilà à
j'étais sur mes d'accord aux usagers ou
par ce sera utile à
alors comment faudrait à x j'ai vu la
corse je défais ok alors on va remonter
là dessus je fasse sauter sur le mec
peut pas comment on va s'y prendre
on va aller sur l'autre côté et d'ici on
va
voilà
je peux y arriver
on est avec toi la réserve
yes
ce paradis tu l'as où tu as tu as un
trauma crânien une jambe cassée habituel
est encore un trou d'homme alors on
ajoute au compte des blessures à trois
gagnants super on va voir si ce truc
marche encore j'espère qu'il marche il
faut que je me souvienne des conseils de
hausse
la condition physique et la technique ne
suffisent pas tu n'y arriveras que si tu
te concentres c'est le seul moyen
d'apprendre à maîtriser une arme
on va continuer plus tôt par là je suis
très ému il faut absolument que je
trouve à manger
bon ça va on n'a pas un timer ultra
stresseurs j'aurais cru que j'aime pas
du tout à part un cerbère ici à il doit
être plus c'est moche unique un oiseau
quoi jusqu'à 12 ans je n'ai jamais mangé
des baisses
quand j'ai fait aux [ __ ] aux [ __ ] un
connard aux bâtards [ __ ] comment je
fais pour arrêter je peux pas mais
arriver là non tout âge suit 3 mondial
sur la pointe amont pour vous des
bâtards [ __ ] mais ils sont sérieux à
courir comme des voyages les tiens
alors on a fléchi limitée n'en a pas
fait limitée du tout j'ai un peu nié
tout méfait je m'en reste une s'écoule
au nom et la hausse très triste non
j'aime pas trop sur eux
ah bon après on à turin par milliers
mais pour mange hf le nom un chef lui
tutu transfert ça vous mettez une
bataille mais encore vivant
ben je suis pas sûr qu on serait tous
capables de faire ça dans son 48 jouer
leur a quand même franchement mais il
est où ton camp était marrante
c'est là-bas d'accord donc un petit
triangle combien pas tu ne disposera pas
toujours des derniers gadgets times en
est une de ses marques et un endroit
très fraîche apprend le langage de la
terre et les étoiles et tu seras
toujours fait les bons choix
c'était là bah ouais c'est cela va
allez j'espère qu'on va pas tomber sur
des vilains en route ça m'étonnerait pas
tu sais qu'ils fassent d'articles
tournée non non pas pu très bien
d'accord feu de camp voilà c'est ça que
je vous disais tout à l'heure
vos points de compétences pour améliorer
vos capacités instinct animal alors une
meilleure observation afin de repérer
des animaux des ressources de voiture
facile à trouver et comment se veut
gagner des récompenses supplémentaires
en fouillant les cadavres d'animaux et
les caches de nourriture au pardon j'en
appelle gt gt faut gagner
fouillez les caisses et les cages pour
trouver des matériaux supplémentaires
fully attentivement les cadavres
d'animaux pour récupérer des matériaux
supplémentaires aux je sais pas trop ce
qu'on peut mettre
agité ça c'était un dlc que j'avais
augmenté à 13 ans les gars tu as c'est
peut-être pour ça que je fais des grands
sauts dès le début d'ailleurs un passant
les fichiers peuvent être récupérées
vous récupérez des flèches sur les
cadavres ennemis alors on va plutôt
prendre ça oui parce que sinon on va
vite à coup on sera au loin dans le cul
d'accord car je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est une compétence devrait pouvoir le
faire naturellement mais bon c'est abusé
d'accord ok donc on a trois arbres
survivants chasseurs dans deux arbres
deux arbres de talents survivants et
chasseurs d'accord donc on veut ça c'est
plus des capacités pour attaquer ça
c'est plus des bonus de points afin de
bouffe de trucs servent en attaque et
justement d'accord ok nickel alors un
seul mâle survivant 23% 100% d'accord ok
très bien d'accord compétences feu de
camp alors qu'est ce qu'on peut voir les
compétences cre est abritée coordonnées
de lieux et tous je me souviens d'un
pelage et puis plus rien je me suis
réveillé dans une grotte y avait un
homme qui poursuit paix et puis vers 15
heures
c'était vraiment vous dis que c'est de
ma faute j'ai reçu sur ma profession
position
tu peux y arriver la ram souvient du
mont sutton
pendant mon gratter du disait que la
seule option c'est sûr nous ici donc tu
escalade la montagne en passant par les
ruines mais y'a un papy l'illimité
coucou coucou à dijon
alors que tu avances et trouver un moyen
de sortir de la forêt je peux manger
annoncé bon fait non ok alors attendez
alors elle est où la bao la base de la
musique pardon voilà bah je sais rien je
sais pas ça semble rien de bon
j'ai pas totalement confiance il ya
quelqu'un
ok on peut passer par en-bas très très
glauque la page ok baa limite mieux vaut
passer par rumba parents aux gens 8 ya
aussi les animaux en basset les hommes
fois que je participe à cette église
ça présage rien de bon put essais j'ai
rarement les psychopathes qui écoute de
musique classique tout doucement sa
merde fond ce temps on retombe de là on
vient pas un mois et à savoir qu'il y
avait quand même des bons petits
psychopathe passion vous souvenez vous
après disait qu'il voulait nous aider
mais j'y crois pas trop en faire non des
jeux contes et ça c'est comme ça en
prison ils comptent les jours y mettre
des bâtons que les raye pas ça la
voyette c'est de la folie
encore lui
je veux je fais quoi
cagim xp et la sq est dans celui-là
alors toujours bien regarder tout ça
c'est vous qui me l'avait appris par an
waouh il ya des traces de peinture
blanche à l'intérieur
la personne qui utilisaient ce masque
est issu de la noblesse au sympa weather
on a récupéré un masque c'est plutôt
cool quoi d'autre
ça on a enflammé d'avis ouest c'est
prévu les deux manières obtint je me
suis justement du sa [ __ ] ça prend un
peu vite parce que tout
quoi
a deuxième arme à la main d'accord on
pourra les améliorer je pense c'est dans
modern warfare qu'ils avaient ça avec la
classe et tous vents w2a suppose que
c'est ici ouais ok donc on peut forcer
l'ouverture d'accord c'est vraiment bien
foutu ok alors on continue et explorant
le denjean
c'est quand même un peu noir il fait
tout noir
michel ici c'est chaud devrait y avoir
une chaîne à quoi là bas vous savez quoi
on va se quitter ici l'échelle est juste
ici et on verra dans le prochain épisode
qu'il ya la surface d'accord alors
sortir un nouvel épisode demain et
ensuite j'irai tous les deux trois jours
pendant les vacances
hélas les autres feront plus long je
vous rassure ça sera à base de 40
minutes 45 milk l'épisode mais là
écoutez je me demande bien ce que vient
au de cette échelle ah là là nous
verrons z à bientôt tout le monde
n'hésitez pas à nous en commentaires ce
que vous avez pensé trop de ce premier
laisse plein mes commentaires de ce que
vous souhaitez ou pas pendant les vidéos
pendant l'esprit pardon et puis voilà
tout le monde puisse et à bientôt
roularta les goblins
vrai
ouais
m